David, what do you think
the patient would select next?
>> So unlike last time,
the first production rule won't fire
because I do perceive a runner on first.
Instead, while I don't
perceive fewer than two outs,
I do perceive a runner on first.
So this production rule will fire, and
now by goal is to get
the batter out via pitching.
That'll skip the next rule and
come down to here.
Given that the goal is to pitch and
we have a new batter,
we're going to add some
information to our stake.
So we can actually now, not just keep
track of the game as a whole, but
we can keep track of this individual
exchange with the batter.
Then the goal is to pitch and
the batter is not yet out, so
we're going to suggest
the throw-curve-ball-operator.
We then look and
see that the batter bats right handed so
the next rule doesn't fire.
So at this point, we've only suggest one
operator, the throw-curve-ball-operator.
So we're going to send
that to our motor system.
So the answer will be that
we'll throw a curve ball.
>> That was right, David, thank you.
Let's summarize some of
the things that David noted.
So, based on the contents of the working
memory, some rules get activated.
As these rules get activated,
some consequence get established.
As this consequence get established,
they get written.
Those consequence get written
on the working memory.
So the contents of working
memory are constantly changing.
As the contents of the working memory
change, nodules can get activated.
So there is a constant interaction
between the working memory and
the long term memory.
The contents of the working
memory change quite rapidly.
The contents of the long term
memory change very, very slowly.